Caption: just all of a sudden got very quiet
Caption: welcome back everybody we are on to our
Caption: last session for today which is our lock
Caption: note so very shortly I'm going to hand
Caption: over to Chris ferry so Chris has a PHD
Caption: and does a lot of work in the science
Caption: field however he also writes children's
Caption: books
Caption: now I had an opportunity to see Chris
Caption: speak at DDD Brisbane a similar event on
Caption: the other side of the country a few
Caption: years ago and
Caption: I was actually super impressed with the
Caption: books and thought it was really amazing
Caption: I got one of the books on blockchain so
Caption: now I know everything about blockchain
Caption: from blockchain for babies
Caption: and I also want to say a huge thank you
Caption: to Chris who received an email from me
Caption: on Wednesday morning
Caption: to see if he could come and give our
Caption: Keynotes this afternoon
Caption: today so big thank you to Chris for
Caption: saving us at the last minute when we had
Caption: a few travel difficulties so I'm going
Caption: to hand over to Chris thank you very
Caption: much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: yeah so thanks for the invite thanks for
Caption: giving me lots of time to consider it uh
Caption: um I was going to be here for the tattoo
Caption: conference anyway so oh I thought I
Caption: might as well come by
Caption: yeah so I'm Chris Ferry I'm an associate
Caption: professor at the center for Quantum
Caption: software and information at the
Caption: University of Technology Sydney and
Caption: that's obviously in Sydney and I lead a
Caption: research group and we do research in
Caption: Quantum machine learning and Quantum
Caption: control so we do like uh low-level stuff
Caption: with Quantum hardware and high level
Caption: Kind of Blue Sky Thinking about what
Caption: we'll do with quantum computers in the
Caption: future
Caption: but I thought since I have you all here
Caption: I'll just read you a story
Caption: uh it's going to be a bit awkward for me
Caption: to try to do this with the book so I'll
Caption: just show you the book on screen
Caption: I think I'll do that
Caption: ah here we go okay here we go The Cat In
Caption: The Box
Caption: it did not sit well it was far too
Caption: confusing so we sat at the Blackboard
Caption: the two of us musing I sat with
Caption: Schrodinger dreaming of quantum theory
Caption: but the math of it all made both of us
Caption: dreary
Caption: what was it about
Caption: we were not content the trouble came
Caption: down to the entanglement and then a
Caption: knock at the door a box but who was it
Caption: for
Caption: we looked in and saw a cat in a box we
Caption: looked in and saw a cat that talks and
Caption: it said to us get me out of this box
Caption: I was happy to see it an extra mind
Caption: right now we needed all the help we
Caption: could find
Caption: and then an idea with the cat's great
Caption: sight it could see a single Quantum a
Caption: Quantum of light
Caption: an excited Adam will Decay a random
Caption: condition the cat might see a
Caption: superposition
Caption: Schrodinger went on next we closed the
Caption: lid to look in the box is what I forbid
Caption: the cat will see and not see an odd
Caption: condition the cat will be in
Caption: superposition
Caption: Schrodinger used this cat in the Box to
Caption: dream up the first Quantum Paradox a
Caption: paradox is something that doesn't make
Caption: sense there must be an assumption that
Caption: is causing offense
Caption: the theory has failed Schrodinger cried
Caption: we must start all over and swallow our
Caption: pride
Caption: but then I smiled to our own merriment
Caption: we have the cat box and Adam to do the
Caption: experiment the scientific method is to
Caption: test hypotheses so our knowledge can
Caption: grow Beyond just the ABCs
Caption: through all of this shaking its head the
Caption: cat quietly listened to all that was
Caption: said a Quantum superposition the cat
Caption: said with the Sigh a silly idea and I'll
Caption: tell you why but I must teach you some
Caption: physics and where it applies
Caption: the lesson began I see your intent but
Caption: the most important thing is the
Caption: measurement when I look at the atom to
Caption: see if it's spent I create in the world
Caption: a Quantum event when measurement acts
Caption: the atom itself is forced to collapse it
Caption: might stay excited it might Decay but
Caption: which it will be no one can say
Caption: but all is not lost we are not throwing
Caption: dice we can calculate some things when
Caption: science gives us advice
Caption: though nothing is certain one thing is
Caption: key physics can tell us the probability
Caption: Quantum probability a tricky concept to
Caption: use it one needs to be quite Adept but
Caption: study the math and before long the
Caption: quantum tune you'll be singing along
Caption: algebra calculus and geometry the more
Caption: math you know the happier you'll be
Caption: the cat was not done there was more
Caption: quantum physics such a rich Theory can't
Caption: be taught in mere minutes the next
Caption: lesson I have is where the name comes
Caption: from I'll tell you why we call it
Caption: quantum you see said the cat when you
Caption: measure my size any number at all is due
Caption: to a rise
Caption: but measure an atom and what will come
Caption: out a single Quantum of energy will be
Caption: brought about a photon of light will be
Caption: let go the atom's energy from high to
Caption: low the photons energy must be exact one
Caption: Quantum of light from the atom subtract
Caption: so you see now said the Box cat no
Caption: superposition no doubt about that when I
Caption: measure I break the quantum effect no
Caption: Paradox at all that you should suspect
Caption: I know all of this Schrodinger quickly
Caption: replied I invented this Theory a fact
Caption: none deny I'm afraid it is you who's
Caption: missing a fact the best part of the
Caption: theory is due for its Act of course I am
Caption: talking of entanglement the source that
Caption: is giving me such bafflement
Caption: the Box will be closed just the atom and
Caption: you a large Quantum thing Becomes of the
Caption: two you and the atom entanglement a
Caption: curious State it's no accident we'll
Caption: open the box and ask just one question
Caption: what did it look like the quantum
Caption: connection I wish to resolve this deep
Caption: mystery so future scientists have less
Caption: misery
Caption: the cat disagreed it's not mysterious
Caption: you have simply mixed up our experience
Caption: outside the box lies uncertainty but for
Caption: me in the Box I will know what I see the
Caption: light from the atom will come or will
Caption: not and not superpose as you have
Caption: thought
Caption: but the cat could see without doubt we
Caption: were not letting ready to let it get out
Caption: so the cat agreed to stay in and wait
Caption: for the atom inside to change its state
Caption: so the child began the Adam and Cat
Caption: Inside the Box it quietly sat
Caption: we waited too the tension was Rife we
Caption: decided to wait for the Adam's Half-Life
Caption: that is the time for the Adam's Decay to
Caption: reach the point of half what it may the
Caption: point of Half-Life was shown on the
Caption: clock Schrodinger knew what went on in
Caption: the Box two possibilities at the same
Caption: time but open the box and only one we
Caption: shall find
Caption: but what had gone on before the Box
Caption: opened from The Cat In The Box it will
Caption: be spoken so we opened the box and what
Caption: was in there the cat sitting quietly
Caption: licking its hair
Caption: cat shouted Schrodinger what do you say
Caption: what did you see do not delay
Caption: it is as I said I saw the photon nothing
Caption: strange at all in the box has gone on
Caption: the atom collapsed a short time ago I
Caption: measured its light as it will now show
Caption: for science to work repetition is key to
Caption: correct errors we need at least three
Caption: but more is better data is gold so
Caption: valuable it's bought and it's sold
Caption: so the cat went back in again and again
Caption: the cat was amused and did not complain
Caption: the results were in and we had to agree
Caption: there was no Quantum magic for the cat
Caption: to see the light from the atom came or
Caption: did not but never them both as
Caption: Schrodinger thought now we are happy
Caption: with no Paradox thanks to the cat
Caption: The Cat In The Box
Caption: and
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: okay so there was lots of words in there
Caption: um they upset Schrodinger I don't know
Caption: if you know who Urban Schrodinger is
Caption: he's a German scientist Austrian I can't
Caption: remember back then it didn't matter
Caption: um
Caption: uh
Caption: but he this is what he wrote It's like
Caption: this obscure paper that he became famous
Caption: for and this was you know this isn't
Caption: exactly what he wrote Because he wrote
Caption: it in German but this is the translation
Caption: so we can read that so one can even set
Caption: up quite ridiculous cases a cat is
Caption: penned up in a steel chamber along with
Caption: the following device which must be
Caption: secured against direct interference by
Caption: the cat in a geiger counter that is the
Caption: thing that tests radioactivity there's a
Caption: little bit of radioactive substance so
Caption: small that perhaps in the course of an
Caption: hour one of the atoms decays but also
Caption: with equal probability perhaps none if
Caption: it happens the counter tube discharges
Caption: and through a relay releases a hammer
Caption: that shatters a small flask of
Caption: hydrocyanic acid if one has left this
Caption: entire system to itself for an hour one
Caption: would say that the cat still lives if
Caption: meanwhile no atom has decayed
Caption: but the first atomic Decay would have
Caption: poisoned it the PSI function which I'll
Caption: tell you about in a minute of the entire
Caption: system would Express this by having in
Caption: the living and dead cat mixed or smeared
Caption: out in equal parts
Caption: um this is like early 20th century
Caption: Germany
Caption: um that's probably another
Caption: uncommon
Caption: um
Caption: so I I changed it for the modern times
Caption: so we have this cool cat that doesn't
Caption: die
Caption: um
Caption: but that you know that was one paragraph
Caption: and and that's one of the most famous
Caption: things that Schrodinger or the it's the
Caption: most yeah it's what he's most famous for
Caption: although
Caption: he did invent the Schrodinger equation
Caption: which is still the equation that we use
Caption: in quantum physics to explain the
Caption: behavior of the microscopic world
Caption: uh and I'm going to tell you a little
Caption: bit about that because today you know at
Caption: this at the center for Quantum software
Caption: and places all around the world we're
Caption: trying to build a new kind of computing
Caption: technology that's built from these
Caption: things that that Schrodinger is talking
Caption: about
Caption: um and he was really frustrated about
Caption: quantum theory in fact he left quantum
Caption: theory to become an Irish botanist
Caption: which is also true and he wrote a book
Caption: called what is life and that became very
Caption: influential to people like Francis Crick
Caption: who went on to discover
Caption: DNA after he stole photos from someone
Caption: um
Caption: so you know he's a an odd an odd
Caption: character and I think he had he stayed
Caption: in quantum physics he probably would
Caption: have figured out some of the things that
Caption: I'm going to tell you
Caption: um in a little bit
Caption: okay so what's all this stuff about
Caption: atoms so you've probably seen a picture
Caption: like that maybe you remember it from
Caption: your high school uh chemistry or science
Caption: class you have this thing in the middle
Caption: and and then the electrons go around the
Caption: outside and the further away they're
Caption: away from the center the more energy
Caption: they have so the lowest energy state is
Caption: called the ground state and the highest
Caption: energy state is called the excited state
Caption: okay so there's two imagine two states
Caption: ground state excited state
Caption: if
Caption: the electron goes from the excited state
Caption: to the ground state we call that decay
Caption: and when that happens energy has to be
Caption: given off there's conservation of energy
Caption: if you have high energy then low energy
Caption: then that energy has to go somewhere and
Caption: that energy is always the same amount
Caption: and that's where the word Quantum in
Caption: quantum physics comes from and we
Caption: usually associate things in quantum
Caption: physics at the fundamental level with
Caption: particles and so it's a photon
Caption: so energy from the electron gets turned
Caption: into electromagnetic energy that we can
Caption: detect and see
Caption: uh
Caption: we'll move closer to abstraction we'll
Caption: get rid of this picture that we draw for
Caption: um
Caption: for students
Caption: and in science we we think of like a
Caption: ladder of energy and you can step up and
Caption: step down and you need to to to step to
Caption: drop down you have to give away energy
Caption: that's the Decay but you can also have
Caption: the opposite which is absorption and so
Caption: for something to gain energy to step up
Caption: then it has to accept a photon and that
Caption: amount of energy has to be exact
Caption: foreign
Caption: so the picture in the book was like this
Caption: you know artistic between ground state
Caption: and excited state
Caption: um you know in in
Caption: physics we draw this energy level
Caption: diagram and
Caption: um since we're all comfortable with
Caption: um binary numbers here let's label them
Caption: one and zero so you can see now that
Caption: this atom can encode a bit of
Caption: information in its energy levels
Caption: and it can do more than that
Caption: and how the the secret to quantum
Caption: physics is to do this
Caption: you put little symbols around it
Caption: and now it becomes what children are
Caption: called a PSI function
Caption: and I'll I'll tell you why we do that in
Caption: a second
Caption: okay so in the book If the atom is
Caption: excited then it hasn't give it hasn't
Caption: decayed and it hasn't given off this
Caption: Photon so the cat can't see anything
Caption: uh if it decayed then the cat sees the
Caption: photon that was given off and the uh the
Caption: electron is in the Lower State
Caption: but what about in the middle
Caption: hmm
Caption: that's interesting can we do that sure
Caption: why not it's quantum physics and we say
Caption: that
Caption: it's in a superposition so it's in both
Caption: zero and one at the same time
Caption: and
Caption: that's the sort of secret to quantum
Caption: physics so it's even though I've labeled
Caption: it zero and one it it doesn't encode a
Caption: bit of information anymore
Caption: um technically it's a new mathematical
Caption: object it's a vector and if you know
Caption: anything about vectors then you can add
Caption: them together so
Caption: in addition to zero and one I can have
Caption: any sort of a combination of zero and
Caption: one as well so this is a new kind of
Caption: information
Caption: that is much richer than our
Caption: conventional notion of bits
Caption: the rule is that
Caption: either when you try to when you try to
Caption: go and look at this information you'll
Caption: see the Lower State
Caption: or the higher state and what happens is
Caption: determined by the rules of probability
Caption: in quantum mechanics
Caption: okay but you never get to see
Caption: superpositions
Caption: so that's the sort of trick
Caption: so uh Quantum information is richer in
Caption: some sense but it's limiting in another
Caption: sense and trying to find the balance
Caption: between those uh is is part of the the
Caption: trick of the quantum programmer
Caption: so
Caption: the the other thing that was mentioned
Caption: in the book
Caption: was these correlations so
Caption: I have
Caption: the atom being in its Lower State and
Caption: the cat seeing
Caption: and I have the atom staying in this
Caption: excited state and the cat not seeing so
Caption: those two events are correlated
Caption: and those correlated events can be put
Caption: in superposition as well why not they're
Caption: vectors let's just add them together and
Caption: that's what's called quantum
Caption: entanglement it's a coral it's a
Caption: superposition of these correlations
Caption: uh so Schrodinger he was sitting outside
Caption: the box and that's what he had in his
Caption: mind okay according to Quantum Mechanics
Caption: these things are correlated and I have
Caption: to describe them in this way
Caption: but I only ever see this
Caption: or this
Caption: so what does that other thing mean right
Caption: what what are these what are these
Caption: things inside this angle bracket and
Caption: straight bracket uh back at me
Caption: um
Caption: basically his his question was what is
Caption: this PSI function so yeah when we when
Caption: we write out arbitrary
Caption: states of quantum information we usually
Caption: use Greek letters and we start with PSI
Caption: and then we run through them all until
Caption: we run out and then we start putting
Caption: subscripts and superscripts and all
Caption: sorts of
Caption: stuff that scares people away
Caption: probably on purpose
Caption: okay
Caption: so the answer to the question there's
Caption: two answers to the question one is this
Caption: object
Caption: is in one-to-one correspondence with
Caption: what's really happening it's what
Caption: describes reality that's one way to look
Caption: at it if you follow that path it'll lead
Caption: you towards like
Caption: parallel universes many worlds the
Caption: Multiverse
Caption: um
Caption: Marvel movies that sort of thing
Caption: um a lot of philosophers and physicists
Caption: like this
Caption: um
Caption: but in the 90s well maybe like in the
Caption: 80s people started to think about this
Caption: what if this object is really just
Caption: information and if we think about it in
Caption: that way
Caption: then we have this we're not constrained
Caption: by
Caption: our physical intuition that that we
Caption: require when we practice physics
Caption: and so in the in the 80s people started
Caption: to think about what we could do with
Caption: this information
Caption: it seems to be richer than
Caption: bits
Caption: um
Caption: could we
Caption: could we just simulate it so I saw a
Caption: talk just just earlier today where
Caption: someone mentioned a turing machine
Caption: so there's the famous Church Turing
Caption: thesis that basically the physical
Caption: version is a touring computer can
Caption: efficiently simulate any physical
Caption: process in the universe
Caption: but that doesn't seem to be true of
Caption: quantum physics
Caption: so in the 80s they invented the
Caption: notion of a Quantum touring machine and
Caption: there's a new thesis the quantum Church
Caption: during thesis by the way
Caption: um if you're ever get into quantum
Caption: physics it's just an exercise in putting
Caption: the word Quantum in front of everything
Caption: that everyone else has already worked
Caption: out
Caption: um
Caption: the quantum Church Turing thesis says
Caption: that a universal quantum computer could
Caption: efficiently simulate every any physical
Caption: process in the universe and we don't
Caption: know we don't have an answer to that
Caption: question of if there's a gap is a
Caption: quantum computer actually more powerful
Caption: than a classical computer
Caption: you'll win a million dollars if you can
Caption: answer that question it's related to the
Caption: famous P versus MP complete question
Caption: um but you probably win a lot more stuff
Caption: if you figure that out so we don't know
Caption: but we highly suspect that a quantum
Caption: computer is in some sense more powerful
Caption: than a classical computer
Caption: and
Caption: in 1995 a guy named Peter Shore figured
Caption: out that if you could build a quantum
Caption: computer there's an algorithm you can
Caption: run on it called Shores algorithm now
Caption: um I don't think he called it Shores
Caption: algorithm but people after him called it
Caption: shorts alcohol
Caption: um
Caption: that would crack RSA
Caption: and so 1995 was really the cusp when
Caption: people started to get interested in this
Caption: because there was money and people tend
Caption: to follow money
Caption: and we didn't have any any device at the
Caption: time
Caption: now we have many commercial available
Caption: quantum computers
Caption: so at the University of Perth I think
Caption: the only commercially available quantum
Caption: computer
Caption: uh in Australia
Caption: it runs on two Quantum bits called
Caption: qubits so not very impressive and the
Caption: largest device
Caption: um is around 150 Quantum bits also
Caption: called qubits
Caption: and you can access that for free over
Caption: the cloud
Caption: or you can pay
Caption: and those devices have been sold to
Caption: governments around the world as well so
Caption: the
Caption: we've seen slow progress but in some
Caption: sense that's the kind of progress you
Caption: want to see for new technology you don't
Caption: want to see stuff like web3 or
Caption: blockchain or whatever where it's just
Caption: type and then disappears this is really
Caption: new transformative technology that
Caption: requires a slow pace because it's very
Caption: difficult
Caption: so it's going to require a lot of effort
Caption: and now is really the time when I think
Caption: people like you in the audience
Caption: might consider getting involved because
Caption: there are devices available
Caption: and they're currently being programmed
Caption: by physicists and if you've ever seen
Caption: physicist code
Caption: you can see that this is going to lead
Caption: to a huge disaster
Caption: um
Caption: there's there's a thriving open source
Caption: community in Quantum development a few
Caption: of my colleagues live stream on Twitch
Caption: Quantum development
Caption: so it's definitely something that's
Caption: that's happening now and you can get in
Caption: early
Caption: um and and into this new Mason exciting
Caption: field
Caption: um so that's all I wanted to tell you
Caption: today and I'm happy to take any any
Caption: questions uh about Quantum technology or
Caption: children's books
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: I think there's some microphones yeah
Caption: there's one up way up there
Caption: the furthest away
Caption: go over there next
Caption: hi thank you very much that was a great
Caption: talk um if you do you have any
Caption: recommendations on where to get started
Caption: with Quantum development how to get
Caption: involved in the community anything like
Caption: that because it does sound interesting
Caption: yeah so I I I would suggest starting
Caption: with
Caption: um there's there's this non-for-profit
Caption: called the unitary fund
Caption: and it's a it's probably the largest
Caption: open source Quantum community so if you
Caption: look up unitary fund
Caption: um and they they'll give small grants
Caption: and stuff to people who are interested
Caption: in in you know
Caption: adding uh you know adding small
Caption: components to existing open source
Caption: projects
Caption: yeah and and I would say
Caption: the majority of people
Caption: don't have a background like they're not
Caption: PhD Quantum physicists in that Community
Caption: like they're people coming from outside
Caption: of of the of the more traditional
Caption: Quantum Computing community
Caption: so it's it's a very welcoming a very
Caption: welcoming community
Caption: any other questions
Caption: I think there's one down here
Caption: how many cubits are we looking at before
Caption: RSA becomes completely useless
Caption: um
Caption: Millions
Caption: yeah it depends on so
Caption: the problem today
Caption: is that
Caption: qubits are very fragile so a bit
Caption: um
Caption: you know a transistor
Caption: has an error like one in a billion right
Caption: so but if now that you have a billion in
Caption: your device they happen quite often so
Caption: active air correction is is important
Caption: but it's far more important for for
Caption: qubits
Caption: of
Caption: where we're not at the stage where we we
Caption: have error corrected qubits we don't
Caption: have perfectly operating devices
Caption: the better we make the physical qubits
Caption: the fewer we need like the less overhead
Caption: we need the less redundancy we need so
Caption: the estimates now are a million but it
Caption: it could be could be less
Caption: like that's the worst case scenario
Caption: and if you look at the trend it looks to
Caption: be like a Moore's Law of qubits that's
Caption: maybe 30 to 50 years
Caption: from now
Caption: so
Caption: the US government for example has moved
Caption: to post Quantum cryptography already
Caption: because they have 30-year Secrets
Caption: probably so if you have a secret you
Caption: need to keep for 30 years then
Caption: maybe it's maybe it's time to to think
Caption: about post Quantum cryptography
Caption: I have 30 year old secrets
Caption: is there a question up here
Caption: oh over here sorry
Caption: in your opinion did Google truly achieve
Caption: Quantum Supremacy
Caption: uh yeah so there's this idea that
Caption: um
Caption: there's nothing a quantum computer can
Caption: do today that my mobile phone can't do
Caption: as but as quantum computers get bigger
Caption: every time you add a qubit
Caption: uh the complexity doubles so it grows
Caption: exponentially so at some point Quantum
Caption: technology will overtake conventional
Caption: digital technology
Caption: uh and Google claimed to had had done
Caption: that
Caption: probably three or four years ago at this
Caption: point
Caption: but it's it's not something that's easy
Caption: to prove right
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: I think with hindsight we would say no
Caption: that that isn't the case because people
Caption: have improved upon existing ways to
Caption: simulate quantum computers
Caption: that can easily replicate what Google
Caption: did on their devices so it's a sort of
Caption: at the moment we're at this sort of cusp
Caption: where yeah
Caption: increasing the capacity of quantum
Caption: technology
Caption: provides a challenge for conventional
Caption: technology that may easily may be easy
Caption: to overcome because you know
Caption: this isn't something that people think
Caption: about all the time so not a lot of
Caption: effort has been put into
Caption: uh
Caption: simulating
Caption: circuits that are built of
Caption: superconductors for example but you know
Caption: when smart people go and and try to
Caption: figure it out that it turns out that it
Caption: can be done but eventually it'll just be
Caption: impossible there will be
Caption: if you think about it this way
Caption: if you could build the device with 300
Caption: qubits then the number of possible
Caption: States in that superposition that I
Caption: showed you would be more than the number
Caption: of particles in the universe so
Caption: we won't be able to do it with with bits
Caption: of information at some point
Caption: where that point is I don't know it's
Caption: you know it could be now it could have
Caption: been two years ago with but yeah
Caption: I'll also point out that
Caption: they're just trying to demonstrate that
Caption: their device can do something that
Caption: conventional technology can't simulate
Caption: like I can't use a conventional computer
Caption: to simulate what that device did
Caption: that thing that the device that did was
Caption: wasn't useful for anything other than to
Caption: demonstrate that one thing so
Caption: um it's not like it was solving actually
Caption: real world problems or anything we're
Caption: not there yet that's going to require
Caption: thousands to millions of qubits
Caption: is there any other questions
Caption: no
Caption: hi
Caption: oh we need a microphone
Caption: there's one coming from behind you
Caption: oh hi
Caption: that's okay
Caption: quantum computer handle memory leakages
Caption: sorry can you say it again can a quantum
Caption: computer handle memory leakages like we
Caption: Face a lot of memory leakage issues in
Caption: classical computers so can a quantum
Caption: computer handle that
Caption: um
Caption: so there are
Caption: there's a there's a website it's called
Caption: the quantum algorithm Zoo
Caption: and it has
Caption: a couple dozen
Caption: problems
Caption: that
Caption: uh Quantum Quantum algorithms exist for
Caption: that are better than known classical
Caption: algorithms
Caption: but standard things like representing
Caption: data adding numbers things like that the
Caption: overhead actually makes it worse so a
Caption: quantum computer won't be better than a
Caption: classical computer at everything there
Caption: are a few special problems for which
Caption: that kind of new data is a more natural
Caption: or better representation
Caption: yeah thank you
Caption: I think it was up here
Caption: hi thanks for the talk that was really
Caption: fascinating
Caption: um so I have a question uh realistically
Caption: in the future how do you see quantum
Caption: computers are being used will they
Caption: replace all traditional Alternatives
Caption: that we use now
Caption: and if so what what are the top three
Caption: problems that Humanity needs to solve in
Caption: order to achieve that thank you right
Caption: so I think the way that it will progress
Caption: is
Caption: um first we'll see
Caption: a cloud cloud-based devices because
Caption: there will be there will be very few of
Caption: them
Caption: and they also require
Caption: if we don't make
Caption: you know basically Nobel prize winning
Caption: improvements in materials
Caption: these things require extreme
Caption: environments so ultra high vacuum like
Caption: fewer fewer particles than you would
Caption: find in outer space or cools with liquid
Caption: helium which makes these these sort of
Caption: refrigerators that they're housed in the
Caption: coldest places in the universe
Caption: you don't you don't want your average
Caption: consumer I think to have to handle that
Caption: um so there'll be cloud-based devices
Caption: initially
Caption: uh
Caption: but
Caption: even if we end up finding a way to
Caption: miniaturize it and make it work at room
Caption: temperature
Caption: they'll still be special purpose
Caption: components it'll be like you know you
Caption: have your GPU and maybe you have your
Caption: TPU and you'll have your qpu all you
Caption: know handled by it
Caption: you know your existing computer your
Caption: existing CPU will just Outsource
Caption: particular calculations that it knows
Caption: will be more efficiently run on the
Caption: quantum processor
Caption: oh and you had the other question so I
Caption: don't think it'll ever be used to break
Caption: RSA because
Caption: we'll move Beyond uh we'll move beyond
Caption: that
Caption: the most promising application is
Caption: using Quantum systems to simulate other
Caption: Quantum systems
Caption: so right now
Caption: it's very difficult to simulate chemical
Caption: interactions just because again as I
Caption: said you know a chemical might have more
Caption: than 300 atoms in it and so the number
Caption: of states it can be in is more than the
Caption: number of particles in the universe so
Caption: conventional technology has a real hard
Caption: time representing that rich data with
Caption: bits
Caption: and so when you're designing vaccines
Caption: and drugs and stuff you're you can do
Caption: some heuristic things and you can do
Caption: really coarse grain simulations but
Caption: ultimately
Caption: you have to make a guess
Caption: build the drug stick it in mice find out
Caption: what happens right
Caption: in the future if we're able to simulate
Caption: the interaction between biological
Caption: models in a virtual environment then
Caption: that will just that will be truly
Caption: transformational we'll be able to design
Caption: new drugs new vaccines new materials all
Caption: in a virtual environment before we have
Caption: to go out and spend the money to to
Caption: build the actual thing
Caption: I think that'll be the number one
Caption: uh yeah the number one application
Caption: where's the microphone I can't see
Caption: oh here
Caption: um how come you didn't say study Physics
Caption: as a prerequisite to getting into
Caption: Quantum computing
Caption: so
Caption: uh quantum mechanics study Physics
Caption: physics background have a Physics degree
Caption: it's like studying computer science to
Caption: do programming Etc so fundamentals
Caption: I think I mean that's just a historical
Caption: Quirk that the people who invented the
Caption: field were physicists and so the
Caption: language in jargon is all physics jargon
Caption: but that's changing so at the University
Caption: of Technology Sydney you can get a
Caption: Bachelor of Computer Science and major
Caption: in Quantum computation so I teach
Caption: introduction to Quantum computation to
Caption: people who've never taken a Physics
Caption: course at all
Caption: there's no physics jargon in it and we
Caption: start with programming we build a
Caption: Quantum tic-tac-toe game and we run it
Caption: on a quantum computer and they don't
Caption: need to I mean I could do it without
Caption: even using the word superposition and
Caption: entanglement you know once you just
Caption: specify the rules and the grammar and
Caption: the syntax of the quantum programming
Caption: language then it's just like any other
Caption: computer science
Caption: did the microphone
Caption: hello
Caption: um so schroding is cat represented an
Caption: era of quantum Computing
Caption: um where we had Leaps and Bounds in
Caption: Discovery and understanding but that was
Caption: like the 20s like 1920s and 1930s what
Caption: do you think is next for quantum theory
Caption: like the next big thing
Caption: oh that's a good question
Caption: so the
Caption: you know the questions that Schrodinger
Caption: raised are unresolved
Caption: um
Caption: you know we don't
Caption: we don't really know what the nature of
Caption: reality is we know that quantum
Caption: mechanics is wrong in some sense
Caption: we have two main theories in physics
Caption: Einstein's theory of general relativity
Caption: which works for large-scale things
Caption: and quantum mechanics which works for
Caption: small scale things and they're
Caption: completely incompatible so one of them
Caption: is wrong or they're both wrong which is
Caption: the more likely scenario uh and that's
Caption: kind of what most theoretical physicists
Caption: think about at least the ones that
Caption: um have tenure
Caption: they
Caption: they think about how do you bring these
Caption: two things together you know it's what
Caption: Einstein spent the most most of his life
Caption: trying to figure out
Caption: I mean he kind of invented both of the
Caption: theories and then spent the rest of his
Caption: life trying to put them together uh
Caption: so doing that or coming up with a
Caption: completely new theory that supersedes
Caption: both general relativity and quantum
Caption: mechanics and you can get some pretty
Caption: wild speculations like the universe is a
Caption: hologram
Caption: um or you know a black hole is really a
Caption: quantum computer these sorts of things
Caption: uh are what people talk about at
Caption: theoretical physics conferences
Caption: I
Caption: I yeah
Caption: um
Caption: I guess I'm not old and cranky enough to
Caption: think about that sort of stuff I still
Caption: write
Caption: I just write research grants and
Caption: children's books
Caption: are there any other questions
Caption: there's one down here
Caption: oh and there's one over there
Caption: uh thanks for your talk I was going to
Caption: change Tech and talk about your uh you
Caption: know being an author can you describe a
Caption: bit of your creative process from being
Caption: a scientist to then communicating what a
Caption: quiet you know obscure or perhaps
Caption: esoteric Concepts to such a junior
Caption: audience I mean what do you how do you
Caption: even start that process
Caption: yeah so I think
Caption: the motivation obviously was to for my
Caption: to read to my own kids so I have four
Caption: children and
Caption: I wanted to
Caption: read science books to them and this was
Caption: maybe eight years ago
Caption: it didn't really exist
Caption: so I thought well I'll just try to do it
Caption: myself and and
Caption: what better thing to write about for
Caption: children than quantum physics and so I
Caption: wrote
Caption: I wrote quantum physics for babies and
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: I I kind of approached it as I would my
Caption: my own sort of teaching so I don't
Caption: really
Caption: distinguish between an audience a
Caption: physicists and an audience of children
Caption: um you know just
Caption: key
Caption: keep it simple
Caption: and use bright diagrams
Caption: um
Caption: yeah and so I did that and it seemed to
Caption: work out and some of the other like the
Caption: book here was kind of modeled
Caption: um Loosely on
Caption: um you know the cat the cat in the hat
Caption: um although
Caption: this isn't going to go live oh it is
Caption: live
Caption: so if the Dr Seuss Foundation is
Caption: listening it you didn't hear that part
Caption: um
Caption: so I you know as a physicist or as a
Caption: scientist you you're just naturally
Caption: attuned to taking things that people
Caption: have built and and simplifying them or
Caption: looking at them in a different way or
Caption: building upon them
Caption: um usually to make them better now I
Caption: don't want to say that I made something
Caption: better than Dr Seuss but the point is
Caption: it's much easier to take something that
Caption: exists
Caption: and then put your own spin or
Caption: Improvement upon it and that's kind of
Caption: what scientists do all the time nobody
Caption: just invents a theory and vacuum right
Caption: they they build upon the previous thing
Caption: it's all incremental and so for me it
Caption: seems really like it's just a natural
Caption: thing for me to do to say take something
Caption: that exists and I know that works well
Caption: and then add my own flavor to it
Caption: can I
Caption: um
Caption: so like we see like say AI in the last
Caption: 10 years there's been a lot of like
Caption: debates about ethics ethical problems
Caption: and the such is there anything any
Caption: um debates of that saw in the quantum
Caption: world
Caption: it is it's very uh there's not a lot of
Caption: people thinking about it
Caption: um
Caption: so yeah I think there was a white paper
Caption: about about Quantum ethics
Caption: um
Caption: and you know it's largely inspired by
Caption: the debate in AI
Caption: and
Caption: the argument is let's get on top of this
Caption: now
Caption: or we're going to end up like AI
Caption: with a whole bunch of things to fix in
Caption: the future
Caption: but
Caption: you know without
Caption: I think you really you can you we're
Caption: watching an experiment right and the
Caption: hypothesis is
Caption: does money talk and yet yes it does so
Caption: there's no money being put into that
Caption: effort
Caption: and there's money being put into just
Caption: going and moving forward as fast as
Caption: possible
Caption: um so it's it's going to be a challenge
Caption: I my suspicion is like most things so
Caption: just we're going to forge ahead with a
Caption: lot of stuff to clean up afterward but
Caption: there there is there is
Caption: so one of the one of the differences is
Caption: that the promise of quantum technology
Caption: and the likely path forward is that
Caption: at some point in the future there'd be
Caption: only a handful of these devices and
Caption: they'll be extremely powerful
Caption: like they can break RSA
Caption: so there won't be Democratic access to
Caption: these these things
Caption: um
Caption: because of the way things are structured
Caption: and so that that's sort of the the major
Caption: difference
Caption: um in the debate
Caption: between the quantum ethics and AI ethics
Caption: but certainly something that people
Caption: think about
Caption: just not enough
Caption: any more questions
Caption: I see one just kind of following up from
Caption: that uh the what you're just talking
Caption: about
Caption: um so what does the career like look
Caption: like in Quantum Computing for let's say
Caption: a student going through one of your
Caption: classes right now what is the let's just
Caption: say they're in their 20s and they're
Caption: going to spend an entire career what do
Caption: you what do you think it would look like
Caption: yeah so the quantum industry is large
Caption: enough at this point
Caption: that the majority of people that are in
Caption: it
Caption: um don't really know anything about
Caption: Quantum Computing at all so you know a
Caption: Quantum Computing company
Caption: so I would say a Quantum startup company
Caption: needs to have a website so it needs web
Caption: designers right and
Caption: I I work closely with a couple Quantum
Caption: startups and you need remarkably little
Caption: knowledge about Quantum Computing to if
Caption: you have if you're a talented developer
Caption: then you can learn all all you need to
Caption: know on the on the job
Caption: in so in our degree program there's kind
Caption: of two Pathways there's sort of the
Caption: honors
Caption: higher education pathway so if you want
Caption: to be like a research scientist at a
Caption: Quantum company then you still need a
Caption: some some higher degree probably a PhD
Caption: but then there's sort of the technology
Caption: pathway
Caption: where you'll be a computer scientist but
Caption: the quantum company won't have to spend
Caption: eight months on some special induction
Caption: about about Quantum Computing for you so
Caption: you'll already be kind of well-versed in
Caption: all of the language in lingo and nuances
Caption: that you would otherwise have to learn
Caption: on the job but I speak to people who
Caption: work at Quantum startup companies
Caption: and they're like yeah I don't know I
Caption: don't know any I don't know what like I
Caption: I someone told me to program this thing
Caption: and I did it but I have no idea what it
Caption: means
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: oh yeah
Caption: probably like devs have you seen devs
Caption: yeah if you haven't yeah devs is
Caption: probably the if you really want to
Caption: figure out what a Quantum startup
Caption: is like watch the I think it's on uh
Caption: FX in in the US and then it's
Caption: I don't remember what what streaming
Caption: service is on here but yeah it's a
Caption: it's a series about a Quantum Computing
Caption: startup company
Caption: all right thank you very much Chris
Caption: thank you again for joining us today